alicia tomo una muestra aleatoria de
teléfonos móviles y encontró una
relación lineal positiva entre la
rapidez de sus procesadores y sus
precios aquí se muestra una salida del
análisis hecho en computadora de una
regresión de mínimos cuadrados de su
muestra para comprender lo que está
pasando ella muestreo cierta cantidad de
teléfonos aunque no nos dicen cuántos
fueron y encontró una relación lineal
positiva entre sus precios y la rapidez
de sus procesadores en este eje tenemos
el precio y en este otro tenemos la
rapidez del procesador se gráfica la
muestra donde cada punto representa un
teléfono y se ingresaron estos datos en
una computadora la cual entregó como
salida una recta de regresión para su
muestra la recta de regresión de su
muestra que denotamos como ye sombrero
es igual a b por x para su muestra a es
igual a 127 puntos 0 92 y la pendiente
de la recta de regresión es el
coeficiente de la rapidez de acuerdo a
esta gráfica la variable x corresponde a
la rapidez así que su coeficiente debe
ser el de la rapidez
no debemos olvidar que estas son
estimaciones que quizás representan algo
real si pudiéramos muestrear todos los
teléfonos en el mercado entonces
tendríamos el parámetro verdadero de la
población pero como esta es sólo una
muestra tenemos solamente una estimación
el hecho de que ella vea esta relación
lineal positiva en la muestra no
necesariamente implica que esto aplique
para toda la población quizá por
casualidad su muestra tiene esta
relación y es por eso que alicia hace
esta prueba de hipótesis en una prueba
de hipótesis en realidad suponemos que
no hay una relación esta beta de aquí
representa el parámetro verdadero de la
población en una regresión si esta es la
población y la gráfica moss entonces
tendríamos miles de millones de
teléfonos si calculamos una recta de
regresión entonces de acuerdo con la
hipótesis nula la pendiente de esta
recta de regresión sería 0 la ecuación
de esta recta sería alfa + beta por x y
la hipótesis nula dice que beta es igual
a cero
la hipótesis alternativa es lo que
alicia sospecha que la pendiente
verdadera
la recta de regresión es mayor que 0
suponemos que se cumplen todas las
condiciones de inferencia al nivel de
significancia de alfa igual a 0.01 hay
suficientes pruebas para concluir que
existe una relación lineal positiva
entre estas variables para todos los
teléfonos móviles porque pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo por su
cuenta para hacer esta prueba de
hipótesis primero debemos suponer que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera y que esta
es la pendiente verdadera de la recta de
regresión de la población cuál es la
probabilidad de que tengamos un
resultado como éste vamos a usar esta
información y la estimación de la
distribución muestral de la pendiente de
la recta de regresión muestral para
obtener un estadístico t y para esta
situación la hipótesis alternativa dice
que la pendiente verdadera de la recta
de regresión de la población es mayor a
0 y podemos ver el valor p como la
probabilidad de tener un estadístico t
mayor o igual a 2.999 al ver esta
columna podemos vernos tentados a usar
este valor p
lo que lo calcularon para que lo
usáramos y decir que el valor p es 0.004
pero debemos ser muy cuidadosos ya que
aquí nos están dando un valor p
bilateral si pensamos en una
distribución t que corresponda a los
grados de libertad correctos este dato
nos dice cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener un resultado cuyo valor absoluto
es igual o mayor a 2.999 en la gráfica
esto esté igual a 0 y aquí está 2.999
nos interesa esta parte de la
distribución esta cola derecha este
valor p nos da no sólo este valor sino
también este otro valor menor o igual
que menos 2.999 no se está dando estas
dos áreas si queremos el valor p para
este caso entonces nos interesa
solamente esta área de aquí como esta
distribución es simétrica solamente
tenemos que dividir este valor entre 2
esto es igual a 0.00 2 lo que hacemos en
cualquier prueba de significancia es
el valor p con el nivel de significancia
si comparamos 0.002 con 0.01 cuál es más
grande 2 milésimas es menor a una
centésima o también podemos decir que
son 10 milésimas así que el valor p es
menor que el nivel de significancia así
que la probabilidad de obtener un
resultado así o más extremo es tan baja
si suponemos la hipótesis nula que
tenemos que rechazar esta hipótesis nula
y sugerir la alternativa hay suficientes
pruebas para concluir que existe una
relación lineal positiva entre estas
variables para todos los teléfonos
móviles si por qué porque el valor p es
menor que el nivel de significancia por
lo que rechazamos la hipótesis nula lo
que sugiere la alternativa nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo